boisclair il a aussi nié que les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir l'aise
rotenberg et
saleh
[Applaudissements]
et philippe il va avoir sur l'adversaire
tout de suite je sais ça sert toujours
la même on a versé avant le combat
j'adore vous faites mal d'empoignades
pris pour un lieu spacieux avec tout le
monde en fait lancé un regard c'est tous
les matins comme ça au studio ce top
chef ces normes sont arrivés le matin
les génies toi tu es comme ça un petit
peu hattab régir montant de 300 ils
arrivent ils marchent ils voient pas en
panne jeudi au [ __ ] j'ai fait une
connerie je lui dis un truc et il serre
la main de fer il fait dire par là c'est
pourquoi oui bon temps donc il a touché
pendant les jeux
[Applaudissements]
et moi d'accord avec impatience le bras
de fer entre philippe et tu restais au
cap ce mot car il prend ça très au
sérieux de services hyper je pense que
il va il va très mal le vide mais
philippe vous donnerai tout bien sûr
alors philippe etchebest on les aime
parce que il est comme ça moi j'aime
bien les gars comme ça tu vois il dit ce
qu'il pense voilà s'il avait un truc à
dire à gilles verdez il l'a dit il a un
truc à dire un mot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la course
[Musique]
ah la la
à ce bras de fer qui l'attendait
alalalala regardez kim a gagné aa c'est
quoi votre plat préféré philippe moi
j'aime tout j'aimais tout et vous
mokhtar c'est quoi votre plat préféré
naldo bien la loubia merci voilà pour
tous les tunisiens qui nous regardent
alors c'est quoi votre meilleur bras en
fait j'ai des deux bras péter non à un
havrais de biceps rupture du biceps des
deux bras gauche et drouot dont la
moitié n'ont été en moi mais c'est pas
grave
meyer bras le droit vous êtes bien alors
d'accord quand je suis arrivé attention
allez-y les chéris bien sûr vous
connaissez les règles à koudougou le béa
notant qu on va leur attention vous êtes
prêts des lits
attention top à 2,3 partait à oui quand
même
ah ouais tu vas te réveiller en train de
faire route devant toute la france
les force à les mauves ont commencé sous
les halles est légal le bras de fer
il a aussi nié que l'émission allait
ah ah
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]